[Music]
there are a couple of things that Google
searches revealed about sex one is the
lack of sex so the number one complaint
in a marriage is that it's a sexless
marriage much more common search than
loveless marriage or unhappy marriage
the number one complaint that everybody
has about their partner whether it's a
husband wife boyfriend or girlfriend is
that the partner won't have sex with me
that beats the second complaint that the
partner won't text me back and some of
the searches are go again a little
against conventional wisdom there are
twice as many complaints that my
boyfriend won't have sex with me then
that my girlfriend won't have sex with
me and I think we usually think you know
in the conventional wisdom is that men
want sex all the time and women are more
withholding or prudish but I think that
the data from Google goes against that I
think the other thing that is revealed
in Google searches is widespread
insecurity about one's body and with men
it tends to focus on one particular area
which may not be so surprising maybe you
could guess like where men might be more
most insecure it is their their genital
region so men make more question men ask
more questions about their penis than
any other body part on google and
basically always how to make it longer
and one of the top questions men ask
about their penis is how big is my penis
which is not clear why they're asking
Google that all right like you need
that's not really the way to find out
but it some some of that seems needless
because for a woman rarely search about
a partner's penis for every 170 searches
that a man makes about his own penis a
woman makes one about a partner's penis
and there and woman when they're
complaining about a partner's genitals
they're about as likely to complain that
it's too big is too small even though
like men never search on Google for ways
to make it smaller and then
woman not surprisingly also have a lot
of insecurity around their bodies and
they make about 7 million searches every
year for breast implants only about
300,000 women actually get breast
implants so a lot more woman look into
it then and go through with it and women
make almost as many searches insecure
around their genitals as men do insecure
around their own around their genitals
and with women the big insecurity which
I did not know but I learned from this
data is odor that's kind of like a big
theme yeah like men and women are kind
of in their own little world in their
own heads I think so men their second
biggest insecurity after their size is
the length of their sexual encounters
and pretty much your ejaculation and
make it last longer and then women when
they search are frequently looking how
to make it go quicker so it's kind of an
interesting contrast again I think you
do see that a lot of people are kind of
stuck in their own heads and very
insecure and anxious
[Music]